players who deserve
more credit we're going to dispense with
the trivia question we're going to get
right to it peter's first then sims then
me peter you are on the clock with the
first pick in round one players who
deserve more credit in the national
football league
number one ryan ramczyk left tackle new
orleans saints he's a top five maybe top
three nfl left tackle and yet he gets
almost zero attention now for whatever
reason that is but from the time he was
drafted the mickey loomis jeff ireland
sean payton
drafts lately have been very very good
and this was an excellent pick of theirs
three years ago and to me
i look at ryan ramchick and i basically
say the saints have their protector for
whoever it's going to be drew brees this
year and then either taysom hill or
whoever in all the years after and they
never have to worry about that position
for the next six or eight years
yeah good pick by you peter i mean
there's a lot of offensive linemen i
wrote down because they don't none of
them get enough credit for in my opinion
but yeah rams check is you know he's in
the conversation for the best right
tackle in the game and he is dominant
that way so that's a good pick by you
i'm going to go with chandler jones out
of the arizona cardinals i mean you know
the guy had 19 sacks last year he's a
double digit sack machine ever since
he's coming to the nfl and since he's
gone to arizona i mean last year was 19
sacks the year before that it was 13 the
year before that it was 17 sacks and i
believe leading the nfl or maybe second
whatever it may be but you know again i
know we all know who he is but like a
ryan rams check you just we don't give
him credit or put him in the category as
one of the best pass rushers in football
because the cardinals have been a little
irrelevant over the last few years so uh
to me he is a guy that is grossly
underappreciated in the big picture of
things for how good he is and what he
does on the edge of that defense
and i'm going to disagree with you i
think chandler jones gets plenty of
credit he gets a lot more credit as a
pass rusher than my first pick and that
is
vikings defensive end danielle hunter
here's what little credit danielle
hunter gets chris gets his name wrong 75
percent of the time and calls him
danielle or daniel anything but daniel
let's get his name right first if he
can't get his name right he's not
getting enough credit he had 14 and a
half sacks last year got his first pro
bowl bid which he deserved by the way
peter ramczyk got snubbed for the pro
bowl at least on the initial ballot last
year but i think hunter is a guy who is
on the cusp of becoming a force in the
nfl he already is people just don't
realize it yet and i don't know whether
it's because they had everson griffin
there who was the guy who was regarded
as their top pass rusher obviously he's
gone now but but hunter is a cornerstone
member of that defense he set the record
for the most sacks in league history
before the age of 25. uh danielle hunter
much
bigger than uh he gets credit for
my next pick is devonta parker wide
receiver miami dolphins i mean look
he was playing in a patchwork offense
last year with two quarterbacks
and you know obviously neither of them
right now anyways a franchise
quarterback and so all he does is catch
72 balls for 16.7 yards per catch
totally emerged from his previous three
years of slumbering in this offense he
was on the trade block at one point
and i think miami now has a receiver to
build around for tuatanga veloa
yeah that's a good one no doubt about it
he really jumped on the scene last year
he's he's a big time football player if
he health has been the only issue with
devante parker i mean if if he can just
stay healthy he he can be one of the
best in the game and he showed that last
year i'm going to stay at the receiver
position too you know it's a guy that's
being talked about like a lot right now
because of current circumstances
but
we've talked about it on this show many
times who never gets the credit they
deserve and that's mike evans down in
tampa bay i mean mike evans has been one
of the five best receivers in football
for the last five years i mean he's six
five and he ran four three seven and he
just whether it's average yards per
catches catches touchdowns whatever it
is he is constantly open it's not like
he gets a lot of bull crap stats and
when i say that i mean like little game
plan design plays where oh wow he caught
a three yard pass and no he doesn't get
any of those easy type receptions that
way what he's asked to do is run 20 yard
comebacks run 50 yard go routes run post
routes run 20 yard in cuts uh he's got
great size great ability can run after
the catch and yeah i just don't feel
like he gets thrown into that household
name category at the wide wide receiver
position enough just like with chandler
jones because the team hasn't been
relevant enough
yeah but again evans was a first-round
draft pick and i understand he hasn't
gotten a whole lot of credit during his
time in the nfl and he has been better
than people realized but he entered the
league with that pedigree of a first
round pick he was a top 10 pick he was
the second receiver taken he was drafted
before odell beckham jr so he did arrive
with that that
that fame and that recognition and i say
all that because in 2017
my next pick is a guy who arrived in
round seven and the next year his team
tried to draft his replacement and it
hasn't worked yet i'm talking about
running back chris carson who was indeed
a seventh round pick who's got a couple
of thousand yard seasons they drafted
rashad penny in round one the year after
carson arrived in seattle as as a
running back and penny has never been
able to get carson off the field and
they asked pete carroll to coach at the
seahawks from time to time why isn't
penny playing more it's like well
chris carson's pretty damn good and you
know as we go through and one of the
things that convinced me that carson
doesn't get the credit he deserves after
christian mccaffrey signed his second
contract with the panthers we went
through and put a list together of the
other players from that that year 2017
who are next up to get paid
and i i forgot about chris carson i had
to be reminded of chris carson it's like
well chris carson is a guy that i think
we all need to be reminded of because he
doesn't get the credit he deserves for
being the engine for that seattle
seahawks running game all right peter
you're up next round three
i'm gonna take mark andrews tight end
baltimore ravens i mean you know look
this has been fairly well documented but
obviously they traded haydenhurst
haydenhurst first round tight end in
2018
mark andrews third round tight end in
2018.
very rarely does a team ever take two
tight ends that high but the ravens did
and they're glad that they did
not only were they able to trade hayden
hurst and get the 55th pick in the in
the draft back this year
so that they could take
uh dobbins the running back from ohio
state
and and so i mean it's it's it's a
pretty good trade-off for them but now
they've still got two very good tight
ends to sort of build their intermediate
passing game around mark andrews is not
just
you know a a 10 yard per catch guy catch
the ball fall down
14.3 yards a catch over his first two
years
this is a guy who is going to be in
multiple pro bowls
uh before he gets to the end of his
career
yeah he is and he's he's a huge he's the
go-to guy on that offense i mean more
than hollywood brown was last year or
anything i mean the more the more you
watch the baltimore ravens you started
to realize a lot of their game plan
designed past plays were around mark
andrews and his talent so he is he's
integral in their success to run the
ball and throw the ball um all right i
don't i don't like any of my picks today
because i don't get to rebuttal any of
mike mike's just gonna crap on every one
of my picks and then tell me how great
his pick is and i don't get the rebuttal
on any of it i mean what a bunch of bill
crap all that is i mean
chandler jones is better than daniel
hunter he doesn't get the credit daniel
hunter does nobody talks about it
you just gotta you just got his name
wrong twice you just got your name wrong
twice well maybe that's the thing
that's the problem mrs hunter daniel
daniel daniel whatever it's a confusing
name i don't give a damn maybe that's
why you don't get credit okay but my
last pick is gonna be joe joe mixes all
right joe mixon will be my last pick
because joe mixon again is like i feel
horrible for it stop laughing all right
is you know again the running back
position and this is what stinks about
football you know you could be one of
the best players in the sport if you got
no help around you or anything like that
nobody will ever know and in cincinnati
i mean you know they haven't had a great
pass game of course their o line has
been crappy the last few years and
mixon's one of the more talented running
backs in the game you know his stats
show that but all you got to do is watch
the mangoes and watch a game and watch
joe mixon and you'll go man this guy's
special he makes chicken salad out of
chicken you know what a lot to that
offense yes yes yeah i got close there
hot but i did yeah you did
yep so that's my last pick
all right last one for me and you know
what since it's the last pick of the
draft we're almost out of time and you
guys can't complain about it i'm going
with a two pack i'm going with the lions
top receivers kenny gallaudet and marvin
jones jr who are they nobody knows
they're great they don't get enough
credit gallaudet is one of the special
receivers in the nfl and the lions need
to pay him or he's going to hit the open
market and say see you detroit marvin
jones jr had that four touchdown game
last year he got a little banged up
later in the season but those two guys
don't get the credit they deserve
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports